[Music]
I've got back to the floor at the
brilliance one of South world's most
popular restaurants I've been learning
to work the tandoor or clay oven it's
the busiest station in the kitchen now
the pressures really on a service is
about to start
the kitchen is quite chaotic quite
hectic especially on a busy night like
we've got today requite fully booked
when you come out and order what are
they one of the cooks shout back to you
hungie hungie how'd you find you onion
bhaji my three hours practice earlier
was a disaster
oh [ __ ] now there are a hundred and
fifty booked for dinner and I can't let
the team down the food is steaming hot
when the chefs have cooked and the naan
bread which is accompanying it cannot go
out two minutes later or one minutes
earlier it's got to go at the same time
right so is it just better start about
three hours training on earth enjoyable
but don't get that right trust me I have
one pissed-off owner and a burnt pair of
bollocks charcoaled
hang on seven and the first order is in
okay I got new starter fulla butter
tandoori lamb chops aloo tikki hot chili
chicken once under each you can take
care for pieces see kebab first my
cities please
[Music]
the new real anchovy meat slow say yes
chef
you take a wrong skewers wrong skewers
while the kitchen is hotting up my
skills at the tandoor are barely
lukewarm and I'm yet to get any food out
to the customers and the boss is now in
the kitchen which is no laughing matter
[Music]
the pace is frantic what I'm determined
to track the tandoor a big order for
number gives me a chance to prove myself
there we go will I ever crack this
[Music]
that's six no.1 now a six coming out
usually somebody who's just done this
play oven cooking for four or five hours
to put one on bread in there is a big
thing
okay I think I'm getting the hang of it
yeah 40 good job chef
something I learned how to make an ombre
now it's all on the fly lamb chops and
Doric well tandoori salmon - dorri
chicken tandoori makes girls
it's nearing the end of service and
nobody is send anything back thank God
tandoor done next time yes for the first
time you were fantastically good to get
on with the other orders and put six
nuns together with that fantastic that's
the true sign of a chef Matt was [ __ ]
phenomenal I'm burnt - [ __ ] blisters
everywhere and I got charcoal tandoori
arms amazing guys proper authentic
Indian cooking and it's really good to
see because it comes from the heart